ايه ده المشاهدين من يومين ونادي النصر
السعودي خاطف انظار العالم ومسيطر على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعيه في كل العالم
والسبب تعاقده مع النجم البرتغالي
كريستيانو رونالدو
بصفقه وصفت بتاريخيه خصوصا انه رونالدو
بيمتلك امكانيات رياضيه واقتصاديه كبيره
جدا تقارير اعلاميه كثيره حكت انه النصر
كسب افضل رياضي من الناحيه التسويقيه في
عام 2022 وما ننسى انه حاصل على الكره
الذهبيه خمس مرات وانه اول شخص في العالم
يصل الى 500 مليون متابع عبر شبكات
التواصل الاجتماعي واشياء كثيره بتميزه
وما في حدا بيقدر يتجاهلها اكثر من هيك
كمان مجله فورس كشفت انه الدولي البرتغالي
صار اول رياضي في لعبه جماعيه بيتخطى
الملياردولر من اربعه حروف مسيرته المهنيه
واذا بنرجع بالتاريخ لوراء شوي بس لن واضح
الموضوع اكثر واتعود رونالدو للنادي
الانجليزي مانشستر يونايتد ارتفع سهم
النادي بنسبه 8% وزادت القيمه السوقيه
بمقدار 212 12 مليون جنيه استرليني وبالف
2018 كمان وقت ما وقع مع يوفنتوس سجلت
الايرادات التجاريه اعلى معدل نمو على
اساس سنوي بنسبه 30%
يا جماعه ارقام جعالات رونالدو لاعب نادي
النصر السعودي يصنف على انه اكثر
الرياضيين قابليه لتسويق في العالم لعام
2022 متقدما على اسطوره التناسرين والامس
في قائمه ضمت 50 رياضي بحسب سبورت
وبعد اعلان تعاقد رونالدو مع نادي السعودي
بدايق قليل شهدت حسابات نادي النصر
السعودي على منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
وقفزات هائله غير مسبوقه مسبوقه في اعداد
المتابعين بحيث ارتفع عدد المتابعين في
حساب على منصه انستغرام لا يصل الى اكثر
من خمسه ملايين ونصف المليون متابع خلال
اقل من يوم وبلغ عدد عمليات الاعجاب على
بوست الاعلان المنشور في منصه انستغرام
اكثر من 30 مليون اعجاب وهو رقم كبير وغير
معتاد وعلى منصه تويتر كمان حصد التغريده
الاعلان تفاعل كبير على حساب نادي النصر
لدرجه شاهدها اكثر من 60 مليون مغرد وحصلت
على اكثر من 350,000 اعجاب واكثر من
120,000 ريتويت واكثر من
53,000 منشن الموضوع بيستاهل صراحه خصوصا
واللي ما فينا ابدا ابدا انه الانسان انه
العربيه فرده الخبر قبل الاعلان الرسمي
وقرب الخبر يحصل على نحو مليون مشاهده على
حساب العربيه مليونين مشاهدات على حساب
العربيه عاجل
اذا هذا الخبر بالفعل حصد اللي احنا
انفردنا فيه يعني في قناه العربيه حصل على
مشاهدات عاليه زي ما ذكرنا حوالي مليون
مشاهده و بالايام هذه لغه الارقام بتاكد
كل الاشياء ومن شوي حكينا عن هذا الموضوع
فعلى مستوى تسويق بيع قمصان الفريق يملك
رونالدو تاثير كبير كمان بهذا المجال وهذا
اللي صار فعلا باقبال مش طبيعي على متاجر
النصر للحصول على القميص ومن المتوقع ان
يسهم انتقال رونالدو الى النصر بجذب كوبرا
الشركات الاقتصاديه والتسويقيه بهدف
الاعلان عبر قميص النصر وملعقه اما بخصوص
انتقاله رونالدو للرياض فالمعلومات بتشير
الى انه راح يكون في العاصمه الرياض مساء
الثلاثاء بعد اقل من يومين وبحسب التوقعات
في مباراه الشباب
المقرره في 14 من شهر يناير راح تكون
الاولى للنجم البرتغالي مع فريق النصر
هلا مشاهدينا خلينا نشوف مع بعض جماهير
النصر كيف احتفلوا باعلان انضمام رولان
رونالدو لا فارس نجد والعالمي كما تطلق
عليه جماهيره
[موسيقى]
رونالدو
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا في الاستوديو الزميل الوحيد رزق
المصري رئيس تحرير اخبار الرياضه في قناه
العربيه اهلا بك وحيد معنا
خبر كثير هائل وكل هذا الزخم والحايك اللي
صار على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي وشفنا
قديش كمان جماهير النصر متحمسين وبرحبوا
رونالدو كيف راح تكون تبيعات همم انضمام
رونالدو لا النصر مش بس على النادي ولكن
على الكره السعوديه بشكل عام طبعا
في اول ايام العام الجديد طبعا صفقه
رونالدو
بمثابه الزلزال طبعا اكيد موجود كانت
الانباء والاشاعات ومن عده شهور انه
رونالدو يفاوضوا نادي سعودي بعد اصبح
الاسم هو نادي النصر ثم التوقي الرسميه
والعربيه انفردت انه اعلنت الخبر قبل
الصدور البيان رسمي يوم الجمعه
التبعات ستكون هائله اقلها مثل ما شاهدته
في السوشيال ميديا حساب نادي النصر قبل
رونالدو على انستغرام 800,000 تقريبا
متابع الان قبل ما ادخل 5 فاصل سته مليون
يعني عم نتكلم على تقريبا خمس ملايين في
24 ساعه رقم ابدا مش سهل في عالم السوشيال
ميديا والان هذا الاعتدافع وقوه وبيعطي
اشاره ايجابيه لاداره نادي النصر وادي
القائمين على نادي النصر والرياضه
السعوديه انه الصفقه رابحه منذ الان من
ناحيه التاثير الجماهير من ناحيه تاثير
اللي راح يكون على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي النصر قبل صفقه رونالدو والان
بعد صفقه رونالدو اكيد يوجد برنامج من
النصر من المسؤولين في الرياضه السعوديه
للاستفاده من وجود رونالدو في الملاعب
السعوديه رونالدو
اكيد طبعا رونالدو ليس غريب على الملابس
السعوديه لاعب هنا ما عندي سابقه كان في
مانشستر شارك وتواجد في الاراضي السعوديه
كان وجه اعلامي لبعض الشركات في السعوديه
سابقا لك الان واضح مختلف انت الان
رونالدو موجود عندك وبيحسب الاتفاق اللي
تم بنادي واللاعب سنرى كيف يتم الاستفاده
منه اهم نقطه طبعا في اللاعبين وعقودهم هي
الاجراءات اللي هي حقوق الصوره رونالدو
كان دائما حريص في عقود السابقه وهذا واحد
من اوجه الاختلاف اللي كانت بيني وبين
ريال مدريد بحسب وسائل الاعلام السابقه
انه هو يرغب بتكون حقوق الصوره كامل له
ممكن احتفظ بنفس الحقوق مع النادي النصر
لكن الاستفاده تكون بجوانب اخرى نادي
النصر الان اكيد الرؤيه همم التجاريه
والرؤيه اللي راح تكون عند اداره النادي
اعاده التفاوض على العقود الرعايه هذا هو
البنك
يا جماعه عالمي اهتمام اعلامي اكبر الدوري
نفسه رابطه الدوري الان ستجد اقبال اعلامي
اكبر عالميا طلب ملخصات المباريات
والفيديو اعتمادات صحفيين لحضور المباريات
والان عندنا مراحل اول شيء وصور رونالدو
للسعوديه هيكون حدث اول مؤتمر تقديم له في
مقر النادي سيكون حدث اخر كل هذا يمكن
الاستفاده منهم بيعد الصور اول تدريب
بعدين او اللقاء ممكن يتم بث عبر قناه
النادي الاعلاميه او قنوات الاعلاميه اي
فيديوهات له في التدريبات وبعد ذلك ستاتي
الى اول مباراه ياخذها مع الفريق كل هذه
المحطات
شو بالنسبه للناحيه المعنويه همم انضمام
رونالدو لنادي سعودي مثل نادي النصر كيف
راح تاثر معنويا على همم اللاعبين
السعوديين بشكل عام همم على مشجعين الكره
السعوديه وهل يمكن كمان تفتح باب بلا نجوم
اخرين عالميين يجوا يلعبوا في السعوديه
طبعا السعوديه منذ قليل
العالميين رونالدو ليس اول اسم عالمي يصل
ووضعه الكره الذهبيه رونالدو الفائز
بالكره ذهب سابقا في البلغاري اللاعبه في
السعوديه وبالذات في نادي النصر وهو كان
بعد اربع سنوات من الحصول على البالون
الكره الذهبيه في عام اربع سنين 98 لاعب
مع نادي النصر انت الان تمتلك فرصه لتسويق
المسابقه تسويق النادي والاستفاده من وجود
هذا اللاعب اللاعبين سيجدو الى جانبهم شخص
ربما بعضهم كان يعتبره خلال البدايه في
كره القدم بعض منهم يراقبه كان في الملعب
او واجهه سابقا في مباريات وديه وما عندي
اخرى رونالدو يتميز بانه لديه تفكير
احترافي 100% يعني تدريب والالتزام باوقات
ونظام غذائي كل هذا سيكون
همم الاخرين حاولوا في النادي نظر له
والسير على خطواته والاقتداء به يعني ليس
اللاعب اللي همم خلينا نقولها بصراحه اللي
جاي في نهايه مسيرته وخلاص بده يرتاح
ويلعب ربع ساعه عشان دقائق او رونالدو
يلعب 90 دقيقه هذه واحده من الاسباب انه
هو في في سن متقدم بالنسبه لمقاييس كره
القدم لكن شخص وصل لهذه المرحله من حياته
وكان الوصول الماضي ايضا هداف نادي
مانشستر يونايتد رغم كل ممر به انه موسم
الحالي لكن اعتنى بنفسه جسديا ونفسيا
ودهنيا للوصول الى القمه والاستمرار فيها
وهما سيسال استمرار فيه في نادي النصر
ممكن يفتح الباب للاعبين سعوديين انهم
يلعبوا يحترفوا ويلعبوا عالمي يعني
الموضوع مختلف يعني اللاعب السعودي همم
اوروبيه لكن الموضوع مختلف الان البرامج
موجوده في السعوديه للاعبين الناشئين
برامج اعداد اللاعبين هناك برنامج تقوم
همم وزاره الرياضه برعايه منذ الوضع سنوات
وضع عده لاعبين شباب في قاره اوروبا مع
انديه مع اكاديميه يعني هذا ننتظر نتائجه
في المستقبل القريب يعني ليس ب- بمثل
سهوله جلب لاعب
لاجنبي لبناء يحتاج الى سنوات لكن اكيد ان
الكره السعوديه ستستفيد من وجود رونالدو
ومن حضوره الى السعوديه اكثر من اي مبلغ
مالي ممكن ان شاء الله شكرا جزيلا لك وحيد
رزق المصري زميلنا طبعا رئيس تحرير اخبار
الرياضه في العربيه شكرا